we drive past tanks and artillery
positions as we head towards the front
line around the city of Luhansk we're
part of a convoy of journalists and want
to visit a hospital that's treating
casualties from the fighting artillery
fire sounds in the distance both sides
are equipped with heavy weaponry no Hans
is only eight kilometers from he the
city is according to Ukrainian officials
totally and circled and people in lu
han's are suffering from shortages of
water electricity and food but the
Ukrainian soldiers I speak to do not
feel like agreeing to a humanitarian
ceasefire many feel the campaign just
isn't advancing fast enough the real
problem they say is a lack of leadership
at the very top levels of the army not
after which are teaching the city when
grad rockets were fired at our positions
twice in 10 minutes but he took half an
hour before there was a response from
our side and even then only three
rockets by that time the separatists
have smoked a cigarette and hidden the
rocket launcher in a bunker with relief
for democracy a Reiki is a live shot was
shot at it is equally shocked these
soldiers are clearly not happy some
complain of a lack of equipment one
tells us he hasn't been paid this month
and what we hear again and again is that
the soldiers feel like they're cannon
fodder you put that man there's just not
enough of anything our operations aren't
well coordinated and as for US soldiers
well we really don't have any experience
of a battle situation well that's mutant
according to put some orbit on way we
were used we suffer losses every day
soldiers are being killed military
equipment destroyed how many tanks have
we lost
after months of fighting no one expects
to be able to return home any time soon
we on the other hand are sent back it's
too dangerous to proceed we're told the
area around the hospital that we wanted
to visit is sent to be under fire